uh okay so obviously every day speak is
on it's just speak now right yes just
speak because it will speak for yourself
yes now it's now just speak speak
Rebrand new logo
it's 4 30 p.m Eastern so 1 30 p.m 1 30
p.m West Coast 4 30 p.m Eastern you know
we do everything for the for the east
coast and yeah what is up with that it's
so fresh it's East Coast bias I'll
accept it because I was a East Coast
girl for a long time but you must be uh
let's be honest you had no idea the heat
we're gonna make it as a HC to the
finals did you I did not I did not I'll
be honest I was always Tyler hero went
down holding on to faith because I I
blindly have faith in Pat Riley and Eric
spaulstra although I will say this
the Milwaukee series after the Milwaukee
series I know like I didn't think that
they would get through Milwaukee because
it's Giannis and Milwaukee and the after
that series went the way that it did
then I knew really yes you thought they
would they would get the Celtics well
think about it listen I've done this
this bit like 15 times this week but
you said you can't stand the Warriors
right don't worry so much since 2010
yeah
the Warriors have I think 108
playoff wins I'm sure someone will
correct me but I think 108 playoff wins
the Heat have 106. oh no it's crazy
suppose six finals the Warriors have
been to six finals
it's great we don't think of it like
that
yeah like they've they've been to the
finals two of the last four years yeah
air exposure is the goat man like it was
the Heat and he's never won coach of the
year the Heat Bucks Celtics Heats so the
Heat have been in the finals in the last
four years more than any other team in
the east
they were in the Eastern Conference
Finals against the Celtics last year in
a game seven and two years ago beat them
in a game six so they've met the Celtics
in the Eastern Conference Finals three
of the last four years and beat them in
two of them true it's just it's just
it's a heat bias and I'll tell you what
it is it's it's that man people are
still mad that LeBron went to the heat
they are still mad about it they might
be they didn't hate the heat before that
I'm telling you think about it Dwyane
Wade Shaq Pat Riley Zoe like it's it's
Miami what's not the love about it
there's nothing to hate about it they
didn't get hate until LeBron came there
and no one has gone over it and now
because it's it's not the way that
people want the team to look
you know it's Jimmy and I was like well
like Jimmy's not a regular season
Superstar he's not an empty right he's
definitely like a very unique player and
and the way he comes alive I mean look
he's but oh I think he's five time all
NBA's in his career you know it's
six-time All-Star I mean he's a great
player but he's not a player that people
he's not flash he's not Flash
he doesn't look the way people want it
to look it but I'm just telling you
there's all these random dudes that they
they got from like other teams like
Caleb Martin and the Gabe Vincent guy
who's under he the heat with Pat Riley
and Eric Spoelstra have had a dynasty
for since 2010. yeah I mean yeah they
got the only difference is
KD had that time with the Warriors oh
trust me I know and listen I've had to
come to the terms of I hung out with
Kevin Durant during the pandemic once at
his house and he was the nicest guy ever
oh yeah he's great and I was like damn I
gotta go on my Twitter account delete
all these tweets people you think people
get mad at LeBron people get so mad at
Katie I don't understand and then he now
he's on my sons so now I'm like
[__] I bought me a pair of KDs I love
Kevin Durant I will always root for
Kevin Durant he is one of my favorite
players to watch I loved him until he
went to the Warriors and now I love him
again
I mean I don't I had no problem with
that I think I'm also a bit desensitized
to it because I thought it was so funny
how people reacted to LeBron going to
the heat yeah so so you were like this
is nothing this is well it also with
Kevin Durant and similar to LeBron
because it was the same thing that I
didn't have a championship with KD I
think people have Rewritten The
Narrative a little bit because of the
way that this the Thunder lost to the
Warriors right because they were up 3-1
people act like Katie just
took the easy way out right
also like he was with the Thunder for
like eight years also he took them to a
finals he knew something about playing
with Russ I think we all have been in
the loop about recently I mean you know
maybe that was not the worst thing to
leave for us because Russ doesn't seem
like the easiest guy and they and they
prioritized Russ over Katie they did so
what are you actually mad about your mag
that he went to a great team was he
supposed to go to like a bad team right
I don't believe in I don't believe in
um
like suffer hustling like he doesn't
need he already did his time he did
seven or eight years in Oklahoma in
Oklahoma City one MVP there went to the
finals there and decided to move on why
are you mad that he went to a great team
and now who by the way was so well run
Bob Meyer is now leaving who knows
what's gonna happen was so well run that
they had Klay Thompson
Steph Curry and Draymond Green and could
fit Kevin Durant on that team sorry your
team's not well run I gotta ask you one
last thing because I know you got to go
uh give me your take on my Phoenix Suns
so I well I just made an impassioned
speech for governor yet so I'll stay
with that I love Booker two I think I
think the coaching is going to be
important yeah I think you're seeing I
was hoping we're gonna get Nick nurse
but he went to Philly yeah I think I
think the coaching hire is gonna be
important it's not Doc Rivers please
role players are also going to be very
important yeah because you you did give
up some depth and you know you give up
whatever you need to give up to get
Kevin Durant but
I think they're gonna look a lot
different next year I think no more
eight and please I give them a lot of
Grace that probably everybody else
doesn't give them because they looked so
good as soon as Katie got there but they
didn't play a lot together that's what I
tell everybody so during the regular
season they played eight games then
remember he got hurt right and so I'm
like guys like we barely are seeing
these guys figure this out and also like
I love Monty Williams because he's
changed the culture of the sun's but
yeah just like zero like real offense
was being ran it literally was like
all right book it's your turn all right
Katie it's your turn
yeah but that doesn't surprise me
because they didn't have enough they
didn't have what I mean they didn't have
enough time I think they're going to
look very different next year definitely
they need some depth right but once
they're in you know they're rolling
together they're going to be a much
harder out I mean they still went six
with the Nuggets who are now in the
finals so it's not like it's you know
you need to hang your head too much
right I know people think Kevin Durant
should win a championship every year and
they were favored and look I I thought
they would go further as well but I
think they're going to look very
different next year it's not over well
I'm a huge Suns fan hopefully we figure
it out
hopefully your heat win the finals thank
you I I also don't like Denver I like
yolkit she's he's just he's just too
good it's like frustratingly good like
when you're because I'm a Suns fan
watching that [__] guy who
looks just so out of shape he's not out
of shape I know but he just looks he
looks like someone in my friend group
you know they're like I should you be
playing basketball like like reverse and
he's just so good it's just it's just
crazy it's just he is he's really he's
an he is an irritatingly good player
he's so irritatingly good but he's so
good he's the next time he's up for an
MVP there's not going to be as much
pushback as there was this time I know
and it's like I really wanted embiid to
win this year me too I did because I
feel like yo he deserves one you know
but damn if
if yogic proved everybody who voted for
him being wrong I mean
I mean at and then I was like what also
yoga shouldn't win three in a row
because he hasn't done anything in the
postseason yet I'm like all right well
not not y'all call me a hypocrite but I
don't like to play that game though too
much listen it was a regular season
award and be led league in scoring jokic
took the last he absolutely deserved it
I mean he he deserved it it's he's
playing with James Harden it's not the
easiest thing maybe we should make a
postseason MVP I agree I'm surprised I
haven't done that yet well
it's like the finals MVP but like the
finals MVP is so specific to that series
they're just making up trophies at this
point like the fact There's a western
conference in Eastern Conference like
I'm like this is stupid anyway Joy
Taylor uh you can watch her on TV every
single day
1 30 p.m PST 4 30 p.m EST yes on FS1
speak
I'll go watch it on YouTube too that's
where I watch it watch on YouTube thank
you for having me of course